today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video
well we've seen another really
resounding defeat for the anti-abortion
crowd the Supreme Court yesterday said
that no you can't require in Louisiana
doctors who perform abortions to have
admitting privileges at area hospitals
that this effectively violates roe v
wade which is the precedent of note and
thus reminds us why this question of roe
v wade comes up so often when new
potential Supreme Court justices are
being vetted and questioned and what is
particularly interesting about this
decision is that it was a 5-4 decision
where the five the majority was made up
of the four more liberal justices and
Chief Justice John Roberts a moderate
conservative certainly no doubt about it
and we're going to talk more about Chief
Justice John Roberts and his legacy and
is sort of placed within the Supreme
Court on Thursday but for today I want
to talk about this decision that this
really is an important defeat for the
anti-choice movement that seeks to just
ban abortion make abortion illegal
despite the reality of course that
banning abortion reduces legal abortion
maybe at least in the state where it's
banned but it does not actually reduce
the number of women who figure out a way
to terminate a pregnancy and that's
another story that we've talked about
quite a bit on this program so the
reason this is an important decision is
that this is a common way to try to
restrict access to abortion the way it
works in this Louisiana law that was
struck down by the Supreme Court
yesterday and in other states the game
that they play essentially is you you
don't ban abortion per se but you
require doctors who perform abortions to
have admitting privileges at nearby
hospitals and the anti-abortion people
say that this is that the reason you do
this is well if a doctor performs an
abortion and the patient needs to be
hospitalized it's important that the
doctor have admitting privileges so that
that doctor can continue providing care
in the hospital for the hospitalized
abortion patient now all of this is part
of the ruse that includes making
abortion seem like a far more risky
medical procedure than it actually is so
a few realities that we should keep in
mind number one hospitalizations after
abortion are very very rare number two
even if one were necessary a
hospitalization the patient would still
be able to get care even if the doctor
that performed the abortion doesn't have
admitted admitting privileges at the
local hospital and number three there
are bureaucratic reasons that sometimes
make it difficult for doctors who
perform abortions to get those admitting
privileges so this is essentially a
trick from the anti-choice crowd to make
abortions more difficult to obtain and
maybe to dissuade people from seeking
them out in general so understand how
crazy this is five doctors in all of
Louisiana provide abortions two of them
have obtained admitting privileges one
in New Orleans and one in Shreveport the
Shreveport doctor says he can't handle
all of the work alone and the trial
judge concluded that what this law in
effect does is reduce Louisiana to a
single doctor in a single clinic in New
Orleans and that is in practice a
violation of roe v wade that is
ultimately what the Supreme Court found
that the roe v wade decision from 1973
which is the precedent for so much of
the discussion about abortion today
would in practice be violated if this
law requiring admitting privileges at
local hospitals were to remain the law
of the land so
this is relevant for a few different
reasons number one Chief Justice John
Roberts a George W Bush appointee
previously favored abortion restrictions
in two other abortion related cases
we're going to talk more about him
momentarily but in this case John
Roberts coming over with the majority in
defense of abortion rights number two
this is huge because everything is just
going wrong for this administration
Donald Trump as you may know now claims
to be against abortion he was in favor
of a woman's right to choose I believe
is for 67 or 68 years of life his
evangelical followers have fallen for it
hook line & sinker
I guess they believe Trump is now
against abortion and this is another
decision that goes against Donald Trump
stated wishes if we believe that those
are actually his widget wishes now let's
talk about Chief Justice John Roberts
because this is really for me the the
crux of the discussion that now is going
on on Friday I'm sorry on Thursday I'm
going to get into more detail about
whether Chief Justice John Roberts is a
moderate or a conservative of course he
was selected by George W Bush but what I
really want you to understand about this
decision and the decision on daca last
week where John Roberts was also on the
side of we're not going to remove daca
for the reason the Trump administration
wants it removed these are technical
decisions these are not decisions where
John Roberts is coming over to the left
so to speak on the merits of abortion or
on the merits of daca what I mean by
that is in the doc a case for example
the Trump administration just bungled
their case the Trump administration
tried to end daca by saying Barack Obama
didn't have the authority to put daca in
place via executive order the Supreme
Court said that's not a good argument
the Supreme Court John Roberts they
correctly found that Obama did not
overstep Authority but it was not a
decision on the merits of daca and
similarly with this abortion decision
John Roberts is saying in a technical
sense the Louisiana law would vie
the precedent set by roe v wade it's a
technical decision it's not a decision
on the merits now will we take it of
course we will but what's important to
understand I mean look at even the LGBT
discrimination case Roberts correctly
identified in a technical sense if you
allow an employer to discriminate on the
basis of sexual orientation or gender
identity by definition it is a
discriminatory act on the basis of sex
which is banned so what John Roberts did
it doesn't mean he made the wrong
decisions it means he is simply getting
the technical question right it shows us
actually how insane the court is that
these decisions were not nine to zero
this decision on abortion should have
been nine to zero the law that Louisiana
wanted to pass on abortion obviously
violates roe v wade it should have been
a 9-0 decision so the message here
should not be who cares about judges we
got the right decision anyway even with
Chief Justice John Roberts who came over
and joined the liberal majority the
decision should have been nine to zero
and it shouldn't come down to one center
right justice deciding Oh precedent
matters precedent matters that's why we
need Joe Biden and not Donald Trump
choosing more justices because this
should have been should have been a 9-0
decision and then on Thursday we're
going to talk a little bit more sort of
about the political orientation of Chief
Justice John Roberts and other justices
on the court in the last 24 hours we've
seen YouTube Reddit and twitch take some
major steps to enforce their Terms of
Service and weed out what they believe
to be hateful content content that
encourages violence content that
violates their Terms of Service and once
again conservatives are going absolutely
cuckoo for cocoa puffs as I like to say
claiming that this is all about
targeting conservatives that every
platform on the Internet
other than what's that new one parlor or
something
that arguing that every platform on the
Internet are just about has anti
conservative bias
everybody's biased against conservatives
now this may be a tough pill to swallow
for the American right but most
political violence is right-wing and I'm
gonna get to the details of that later
and I know like you know they talk about
anti feh and Tifa has never killed
anyone to my knowledge eco-terrorism
right like you you it's not untrue that
we have seen political violence from the
left but the vast majority of the
political violence and the violent
rhetoric is on the right that's just the
reality and that means that if you have
a policy as a platform which says we
don't allow violent rhetoric we don't
allow encouraging violence against
groups of people based on membership in
a protected class if you enforce those
policies by definition you're going to
sweep up more conservatives now if the
policy was one that either implicitly or
explicitly targeted a protected class
based on race nationality etc they might
have a case but what you have here is
merely a reflection of the reality that
the vast majority of violent language
violent rhetoric and actual violence is
on the right now I'm gonna get to that a
little bit later first what happened who
was banned number one Donald Trump's own
twitch channel was temporarily suspended
hateful content is not allowed on Twitch
the Trump twitch channel broadcast that
old speech Trump made about when Mexico
sends its people they're not sending
their best they're sending you know
rapists and drug addicts and whatever
they rebroadcast that also they
broadcast Trump's Tulsa Oklahoma rally
for a week or two ago and they're also
Trump told this story about it's one
o'clock in the morning and a bad hombre
as Donald Trump likes to say of course
that the word is pronounced hombre but
as Trump says hombre you call 911 of
like violent imagery about his spam
that also apparently violating Twitch's
policies and twitch says this violated
Terms of Service and good for them I
mean there's absolutely no controversy
there whatsoever
reddit banned a controversial pro-trump
subreddit called the Donald it's a
cesspool of some of the worst pro Trump
propaganda around and reddit said that
subreddit promotes hate based on
identity or vulnerability they regularly
post spam as well as malicious attempts
to interfere with other reddit
communities and thus the donald
subreddit was caught up in the ban also
by the way it wasn't only the right in
this case the ostensibly left-wing
subreddit chapo chapo Chapo I don't even
know Trap House was also caught up in it
and then sort of like the really big
news over on YouTube YouTube has banned
conspiracy theorist Stefan Molyneux
white nationalist David Duke white
nationalist Richard Spencer and some
others the reason there according to
YouTube is that all of those channels
are regularly violating hate speech
policy and policies that protect
specific classes of people from targeted
discrimination stefan molyneux actually
posted a hilarious tweet in response to
this where he said quote youtube just
suspended the largest philosophy
conversation the world has ever known
philosophy yeah that's a hilarious way
to describe it but needless to say this
is happening so first of all really
Trump should probably be banned from
Twitter I mean if you just want to do a
cold unbiased reading of twitches of
Twitter's policies Trump shared you know
the white power video on Sunday and
deleted it Trump regularly encourages
the bullying of individuals on Twitter
clearly Trump violates Twitter's
guidelines and if Twitter was to take
those seriously Trump would have been
banned that hasn't happened important to
know number number two you're seeing all
of the same people who insist companies
should be allowed to do whatever
nobody should be forced to bake a cake
for a gay wedding all of those same
people are now saying the government
should force twitch YouTube reddit
whatever those companies should be
forced to allow other people's hate
speech to exist there now they'll come
back and say hate speech is in the eye
of the beholder
okay well you don't run YouTube YouTube
runs YouTube so what matters is what is
hate speech from the perspective of
YouTube now I've sometimes suffered at
the hand of YouTube's whims you all know
that when it came to D monetization on a
number of different issues when it came
to YouTube couldn't tell the difference
between an actual white nationalist
channel versus me
criticizing white nationalism like
listen I I don't pretend that I am NOT
pushing for what would always be best
for me I may not agree with YouTube's
decisions but how do you say YouTube
must be forced to publish what they
believe to be hate speech my personal
view is that more speech is generally
better than less speech and yet how can
these companies not have Terms of
Service and be allowed to enforce them
they can and they are enforcing them now
to go back to what I said at the
beginning the reality is that most
political violence and hateful rhetoric
is on the right it doesn't mean that it
doesn't exist on the left I know people
like to talk about an Tifa etc but we
have to talk about proportion look at
the anti-defamation league's report on
murder and extremism in 2019 76% of
politically murders resulting from
political extremism 76% were
right-wingers of various flavors 3% were
left wingers including anarchists and
black nationalists I think there's a
debate to be had over whether black
nationalism is really on the left I
would argue it's probably not but okay
and then 20% were Islamic extremists and
again there's debate over whether
Islamic extremists are on the left or
right I believe they're on the right
when you
believe that your religion should be the
law of the land and you're willing to
kill over your religious beliefs that's
not any kind of left-wing belief that
I've ever seen
but regardless these are not small
margins the numbers are ultra clear so
when YouTube or twitch or whoever say
we're gonna sweep up and enforce our
policy when it comes to violent rhetoric
targeting of people based on identity
etc of course more right-wingers are
going to be caught in it because that
type of content is disproportionately
coming from that side of the political
spectrum if you agree with me if you
disagree with me I want to hear from you
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and I hope
that you've subscribed to the free daily
audio podcast that we put out every
single day it's free my friends
completely free it's on Spotify iTunes
stitcher Google Play and all of your
favorite podcast apps the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com let me say a quick thank you
to today's new members of the day that's
Elsa Gonzalez and Greg Foster Elsa and
Greg thank you so much for your support
so appreciate everybody who's jumped on
board and said hey you know what I'm
gonna support something I hopefully
believe in I don't think people who
don't believe in what we do are
supporting us but maybe some are there
was that guy Jimmy from Philly who had a
membership for like three months also
want to say thank you to Michael
Orlando Michael's been a member almost
five years in his todays long time
sustaining member of the day
grab a membership very quickly very easy
easily very powerfully at join
pakman.com so we have completely
predictable and yet Blockbuster
bombshell news related to this Russian
bounty story so yesterday we we kind of
gave you the initial outline of this
story as the story goes we learned a few
days ago thanks to reporting from the
New York Times that Russia was offering
cash bounties it's like a bonus for
Taliban connected troops who killed us
or coalition troops in Afghanistan and
immediately the question was does Trump
know about this did Trump know about
this was Trump aware of this when he was
glad-handing with Vladimir Putin saying
Putin should be part of the g8 let's
make the g7 the g8 again we heard
nothing from the White House for 24
hours then we started getting statements
that Trump was never briefed on it Trump
simply had no idea why wasn't Trump
briefed it wasn't really clear there
were claims that it wasn't considered
credible enough to brief Donald Trump
there were claims that it just Trump
doesn't get briefed about everything
that's going on but it was weird because
we knew that the National Security
Council had indeed taken up this issue
we started hearing from other elected
officials who said well I had heard
about this issue we learned that British
intelligence and top British politicians
were aware of and discussing this so it
started to become a little difficult to
believe that Donald Trump had not
actually been briefed but they insisted
on it Kaleigh McKenna knee Donald
Trump's press secretary when asked about
this
and indeed that Donald Trump was not
briefed because the intelligence was not
credible
I'll say this that the u.s. receives
thousands of reports a day on
intelligence and they are subject to
strict scrutiny while the White House
does not routinely comment on alleged
intelligence or internal deliberations
the CIA director NSA national security
adviser and the chief of staff can all
confirm that neither the president nor
the vice president were briefed on the
alleged French hood Russian bounty
intelligence has he been since brief
since all of these requests came out so
let me back up and say this that there
is no consensus within the intelligence
community on these allegations and in in
effect there are dissenting opinions
from some in the intelligence community
with regards to the veracity of what's
being reported and the veracity of the
underlying allegations continue to be
evaluated so again it didn't really pass
the sniff test we knew it went to the
National Security Council and now we
have multiple sources saying that Trump
knew all along
anybody shocked the New York Times The
Associated Press CNN all reporting about
different sources who say Trump was
briefed Trump knew so let's go through
some of the different claims there's a
New York Times report which says that
Trump was briefed in February of this
year okay so that would be like four or
five months ago and that Trump was
briefed about the Russian bounties in
his presidential daily briefing now the
thing about it being in the presidential
daily briefing is that we know that that
has been a challenging text for Donald
Trump
presidential daily briefings with other
presidents have been 30 40 pages long
and come with quite a long briefing with
intelligence staff Donald Trump doesn't
read oftentimes as he has been given the
briefings he's watching a TV that's in
the back of the room the presidential
daily briefing was shortened short and
shortened all the way to one page one
page was too much so it was shortened to
just a few bullet points with a picture
or two like a graph or a chart and even
then we don't know that Donald Trump is
actually looking at it so it seems as
though it was at minimum in the
presidential daily briefing whether
Trump actually looked at it is a
question mark
whether Trump remembers it is another
question mark because as we've said
before Donald Trump and his memory
problems there have been wide
allegations that Trump genuinely doesn't
remember a damn thing so that's the New
York Times report then we have a CNN
report CNN has its own sources which say
that Donald Trump was briefed directly
about the Russian bounty story in spring
so spring could be March April May ish
the New York Times report says certainly
February 2020 the CNN report says it was
a little more recent sometime in spring
of 2020 you then have a third report
from The Associated Press which says
that top officials in the White House
were aware of the Russian Bounty's
situation early last year in 2019 a full
year earlier than the New York Times and
associate and CNN are currently
reporting and then we heard from
Democratic Senator Chris Murphy who says
that the argument that this was not
credible information is is a wrong it's
a bad argument that he saw the
intelligence that it is clearly not a
hoax and that that would not be a valid
reason for keeping this information from
Donald Trump so on day one really day
two because they didn't say anything
about it for 24 hours when the White
House first said Trump was never briefed
we assume that that was a lie the
details are now confirming it with New
York Times CNN and Associated Press
sources all saying the president was
indeed briefed this sort of reminded me
you know Trump has this hear no evil see
no evil sort of mentality Trump recently
said multiple times I was encouraging
less testing because less testing means
we find fewer cases it would be
analogous to saying if we cancel border
patrol we're not going to catch anybody
crossing the border problem solved
right this is sort of another example of
that if Trump stops reading reports on
terrorism or he pretends they don't
exist or he ignores them then it's sort
of like the Terrorism isn't going on if
he doesn't remember or doesn't read or
doesn't pay attention to the Russian
bounty story it's sort of like it's not
going on and
of course the implications are
absolutely insane Donald Trump allegedly
being aware of the Russian Bounty's
story still was publicly arguing that he
wants Vladimir Putin and Russia back in
the g7 to make at the g8 Trump invited
the Taliban to go to Camp David and meet
with him allegedly after knowing that
they were being paid bounties when they
were killing US or coalition troops
Trump ended up having to cancel that
secret meeting with the Taliban because
things went haywire and people rightly
said what the hell are you doing here
what exactly is the idea here
abruptly getting canceled Trump was
withholding aid to Ukraine an ally aid
that would have been used to resist
aggression from Russia after he was
briefed that Russia was offering
bounties when Taliban linked individuals
killed u.s. or coalition forces so that
none of it is surprising the lies are
not surprising the duplicitous nature of
what's being said it not none of it is
surprising but I think now we don't want
to get stuck on when did Trump know and
did Trump know from clearly was told and
he was told a while ago whether he
retained it or not that's that's a
different question
Trump now knows it's now been what are
we on day five since this story broke
what is Trump doing now what has Trump
done since finding out last week we're
hearing very little about that and that
is arguably as important a story as when
Trump knew and who told him okay
now let's talk about Donald Trump's
press secretary Kelly Mack and Annie
defending Donald Trump's white power
tweet this is just completely
unconscionable yesterday I told you that
Donald Trump put out a tweet over the
weekend which included a video in which
one of his supporters yells white power
at anti-trump protesters Donald Trump's
exact tweet was quote thank you to the
great people of the villages the radical
left do nothing Democrats will
all in the fall corrupt Joe is shot see
you soon here is the video that Trump
shared with that comment you'll notice
that about eight seconds in you hear
this guy yell white power twice so first
earlier yesterday on Fox & Friends
Donald Trump's press secretary Kelly
Mack and Annie said Trump didn't hear
the white power part now that's weird
because the white power part is eight
seconds into the video but that's what
Caylee Mac and Annie said yesterday on
Fox and Friends the president tweeted
out that tweet yesterday and took it
down if you played it it was a guy
saying white supremacy it was another
woman or white you know white power
white power and then the woman was
yelling obscenities because she doesn't
like the president at some of the guys
that were in the parade down at the
villages what's the president's response
did he know what he was tweeting when he
did he accidentally tweet that so the
president did not hear that phrase and
that portion of the video and when it
was signaled to him that this was in
there he took that tweet down now
there's already a lie there reports are
not that Trump immediately took it down
as soon as he found out about the white
power thing the reports are that aides
spent three hours trying to convince
Trump to take the video down despite
making it clear up front that there's a
guy saying white power in the video so
Kaley saying oh as soon as Trump found
out about white power he took it right
down that's a lie
three hours is not immediately taking it
down but then she says hey you know he
does stand with his supporters at the
villages even the guy who said white
power even if I guess he doesn't stand
by the white power comment take a look
at that but he made very clear to me
that he stands with the people of the
villages are great seniors men and women
in the villages who support this
president he stands for them and his
point in tweeting out that video was to
stand with his supporters who are
oftentimes demonized so we didn't hear
that portion he took it down but he does
stand with the men and women of the
villages we are truly living
in some of the stupidest times that I
can remember and I guess by saying Trump
still supports his supporters but not
white power she's saying she still
supports the guy who yelled white power
just not yelling white power I guess I
mean it's completely incoherent that was
on Fox
later yesterday Kaley did a press
briefing and during the press briefing
the question was asked did Trump even
watch the video because the white power
part it's not like two minutes in it's
eight seconds in and Kaley says yes he
watched it but he didn't hear anybody
say white power Thank You Kelly I wanted
to go back to the tweets of President
Putin yesterday and then we moved
rephrase what power and devotion
and that when it looks
with their feet down
so the president retweet other people's
tweets and be
we did not hear that particular phrase
when he tweeted out the video and he did
and he did not hear that particular
phrase Trump watched the video but
didn't hear the shouts of white power
eight seconds in I guess that's the
story they're going for so I my message
with all of this listen you all know
Trump lies all the time in his
administration lies all the time
my message to you is how stupid does he
think his followers are if these are the
explanations they give Oh Trump wasn't
briefed on Russian bounties we now have
three credible reports that he was
briefed as long as a year more than a
year ago
15 months ago Oh Trump didn't hear
anybody yell white power it's eight
seconds in did Trump watch the video
yeah he watched the video
he just didn't hear anybody L white
power the disdain that they have for
their supporters is stunning if they
believe their supporters will fall for
the stuff and what sad is a lot of the
supporters do and that is something that
you know when when when we go and we
think about voting in November we have
to remember that even if we're not
falling for these obvious lies from
Trump supporters from Trump meant to
trick his supporters the supporters are
falling for it we're going to talk about
some more of those lies later about
protests and coronavirus cases and the
like make sure you're following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show follow me on Instagram at
David Pakman for continued coverage of
my very safe socially distant vacation
here in Martha's Vineyard we'll take a
quick break and be back with so much
more right after this
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on your support and the easiest way is
through membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show there's an
absolutely stunning new report from a
longtime investigative journalist Carl
Bernstein about what is going on behind
the scenes with Donald Trump and
multiple Trump administration officials
believe number one that Donald Trump is
completely delusional on the basis of a
bunch of different phone calls he's had
with world leaders and number two that
Donald Trump's phone calls with world
leaders actually represent a security
threat and I'm going to go through some
of the allegations I encourage you to
read Carl Bernstein's primary reporting
directly because it is really really
important so just a few highlights from
from the report multiple sources
describe Trump as bullying and
belittling allies while fawning over
autocratic leaders no surprise there
sources say Trump behaved in near
sadistic fashion with female leaders
that he talks to Putin as if there are
two guys in a steam bath and that
Turkish president air Dewan quote took
Trump to the cleaners Trump's behavior
was said to be so unusual and erratic
that it convinced senior administration
officials that the president was quote
delusional and this includes officials
like national security adviser HR
McMaster former of course almost
everybody's former with Trump former
national security adviser John Bolton
former defense secretary Jim mattis
former Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
former White House chief of staff John
Kelly and intelligence officials
they believed that Trump was often
delusional that he was disconnected from
reality in terms of what was going on in
some cases according to Karl Bernstein's
report Trump's actions led White House
officials to conclude that the president
posed a national security threat these
are the people who were supposed to be
the top protectors of the American
people from national security threats
many of them believed that the president
himself was the national security threat
details about phone calls
Trump would get on the phone with other
heads of state including Mohammed bin
Salman from Saudi Arabia including Kim
jong-un the North Korean dictator and on
the phone with them Trump would brag
about his wealth about his genius about
his accomplishments about how bad some
former presidents were the quote idiocy
of former US presidents according to
multiple sources that sounds delusional
to me
that seems like not just delusional but
it seems also a weaponized narcissism is
maybe a term I would apply now as usual
you know every time you get one of these
reports including from a very respected
investigative journalist like Carl
Bernstein who understands the
journalistic process Watergate reporter
along with Bob Woodward you immediately
just get Trump followers who just say
it's all lies it's all fake news
Bernstein did this report wrote this up
and it was published by CNN you can't
trust that it's all lies
none of this goes against what we know
about Donald Trump you know if we got a
report that this was something George W
Bush did I didn't vote for george w bush
I think Bush was a terrible president
but it doesn't sound like George W Bush
that he would be bragging about his
wealth and business accomplishments you
know with the Texas Rangers or whatever
oil money whatever when getting on the
phone with with with autocratic leaders
it just wouldn't really match everything
else we knew about George W Bush Bush
was a terrible president but that's not
something he would do everything about
this report is a
exactly what we would expect Donald
Trump to do based on what we already
know about the guy not surprisingly
Trump would often attack female allies
of the United States who are or were
world leaders
British prime minister Theresa May
German Chancellor Angela Merkel were
regular targets of Trump during phone
calls with other leaders in addition to
Merkel in May but number one Trump would
also bully Merkel in May when on the
phone with them but sources also say
Trump would regularly bully and
disparage other leaders of allies like
for example French president Emmanuel
macron Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau Australian prime minister Scott
Morrison the calls were quote so unusual
to German officials that German
officials did everything they could to
cover up the content of these phone
calls this is what happens when you put
a reality-show guy who's known for
firing people on camera in charge of the
United States of America it's just not
surprising there's nothing surprising
about this it's extremely disturbing it
highlights the urgency of removing this
malignant narcissist as soon as possible
but you know we saw what happened at the
Helsinki summit we saw what happened
with multiple North Korea summits every
single scandal you know it all clearly
has been pointing in this direction who
knew right that the guy who asked a
foreign country to hack his political
opponent back in 2016 who could have
predicted that he might not be the best
guy for national security so the
trumpets are going to write this off who
cares we understand what's going on we
can distinguish between a believable and
an unbelievable claim about Donald Trump
all of this falls squarely under the
bucket of very very much believable and
that gets us to our next story which
which I want to go into some detail on
we have ourselves today one of those
stories that sounds completely
believable based on everything we know
is being widely reported by multiple
sources and is being called the
completely false
the Trump administration now I want to
be really clear I'm going to tell you
what's being asserted I do not believe
that this is actually going to happen
okay so let me tell you that upfront but
ultimately the story does come down to
who do you believe a Republican Party
operative told Fox News that Donald
Trump is number one in an extremely
fragile state that's the word that was
used fragile state and that he may drop
out of the 2020 presidential race if
Trump doesn't believe that he has a shot
at being reelected President of the
United States now there's a lot to
discuss here publicly Donald Trump has
been saying he doesn't even believe the
polls that show him losing to Joe Biden
that's what Trump has been saying
publicly privately we keep hearing more
and more that suggests Trump does
believe it getting on the phone with his
campaign manager Brad Parr scale and
yelling at him and saying how the hell
am I losing to Joe Biden he may have
used a different word than he'll now new
reports that Donald Trump privately
knows that he is losing one person who's
talking about this is fox business
reporter Charlie Gasperi know now you
know I know Fox Business give me a break
Charlie Gasperi no I actually know a bit
about Charlie gasps Bernie knows
journalistic past he's been interviewed
in a number of good documentaries I've
seen Charlie gasps Perino is not the
type of guy to just make stuff up and I
don't believe he would make this up and
he posted in a series of tweets quote
Republican operatives are for the first
time raising the possibility that Trump
could drop out of the race if his poll
numbers don't rebound over the weekend I
spoke to a sample of major players one
described Trump's current psyche as
fragile I'm not convinced yet says
Charlie Gasperi no he's got time and
he's running against an opponent who is
literally hiding in his basement plus
the public isn't focusing yet on just
how left-wing Joe Biden has become so
much so he can bring himself to denounce
rioting I think he believes he can't
that said
the speculation indicates how tense
Republican operatives are about Trump
losing and the party
using the Senate and having their entire
agenda abolished in a leftist wave
election again lots of time and Trump
has endured a horrible couple of months
but that's the snapshot a second source
also says that they've heard the talk
about Trump dropping out but they don't
believe it is true now publicly Trump
insists the polls that have him losing
are fake phony polls on average Trump is
losing by nine to Joe Biden but he
tweeted for example yesterday sorry to
inform the do-nothing Democrats but I am
getting very good internal polling
numbers just like 2016 the New York
Times polls are fake the Fox News polls
are a joke
do you think they will apologize to me
and their subscribers again when I win
people want law order safety so the
claim is privately Trump is behaving
very differently he is fragile
he believes the polls and he might even
drop out so that's the story as it's
been percent presented now here's what I
think I don't think it's gonna happen
I don't believe Donald Trump is dropping
out look at how Trump has been going
after Twitter Twitter is terrible
Twitter is horrible Twitter is biased
well why not stop tweeting no Trump is
tweeting more than ever in the same way
I think that what's going on is that yes
Trump is fragile right now yes there are
people around Trump telling him that he
really is losing and on top of that
there are Republican operatives who want
Donald Trump to drop out so I believe
that what's going on is that there are
Republicans who recognize this is bigger
than Trump if Trump stays in and loses
badly which he might or he might not we
might lose the Senate we could lose more
seats in the House we could lose
governor's races and they are seeing
that if that happens you could have a
decade of a significant push to the left
that would undo a lot of the judicial
victories that the Trump administration
has had thanks to Mitch McConnell it
could undo a
lot of the things that Donald Trump has
started to do so
Trump focuses on no one but himself
there is a world in which if Trump was
genuinely convinced I have no chance to
win in November that he drops out I'm
not denying that Trump is not going to
be convinced that he has no chance to
win in November and thus I don't think
there's any chance that Trump is
dropping out I think what you are seeing
here is sort of a rumor management by
Republicans trying to put the idea in
Trump's head that he's thinking of
dropping out so that maybe he will
actually do it to maybe help the
Republican Party bigger picture I don't
think he's going to do it let me know if
you have a different take I think this
is Republicans pushing the idea onto
Donald Trump
remember that I am now bookable on cameo
cameo dot-com slash David Pakman or just
search my name in the app we'll take a
quick break and be back after this we're
going to talk about Republican
congressman Dan Crenshaw in just a
couple of minutes the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
okay so I want to talk a little bit
today about Republican congressman Dan
Crenshaw he was on the Joe Rogan program
not that long ago and he said a bunch of
stuff that really didn't make sense
about socialism and healthcare and Joe
Rogan pretty effortlessly sort of made
mincemeat of Dan Crenshaw's arguments
and I did a story about it and there was
great interest in it and clearly some of
my audience has been following Dan
Crenshaw since because I got a bunch of
emails this morning about an interview
that Dan Crenshaw gave to Fox & Friends
I believe it was yesterday and I want to
go through some of the things in this
interview because it actually seems dan
Crenshaw is a dangerous guy in a very
particular way he seems not just
uninformed but actually delusional and
he presents his delusional uninformed
ideas in an eloquent and sort of Ben
Shapiro type way where it's like wow he
seems so convinced that this is so
obviously the truth that it clearly must
be even when what he's saying doesn't
really make any sense and as a result
he's become a real conservative hero to
a lot of right-wingers who were just
looking to have red meat thrown at them
and talking points that they can use so
this this is it it's scary to see that
he's almost becoming like a pseudo
intellectual figure among some on the
right and I know you'll be scared by
that idea but I wanted to get into a
just a couple of the things he said
yesterday during this Fox and Friends
interview so first of all here he is
railing against Marxism which he says
there's been a concerted effort to bring
to the United States for decades take a
listen to this always part of the plan
it has been for decades actually and and
it started well back into into one tool
and Marxism made its way into the United
States in the 60s and they're always
looking to to take advantage of some
kind of situation to make people think
that their country is evil so that they
can justify their own Marxist revolution
that is what's happening here and and
you can't be blind to that the plan for
decades for Marxism to come to the
United States
in order to make people believe the
United States is evil in order to cause
a Marxist revolution so what he's taking
here is like maybe a 1% accurate idea
that in Marxism there is this idea that
when capitalism fails there will be a
revolution which will usher in a marxist
state that that that's a Marxist idea
that's true but you've really got a
breakdown what he's saying piece by
piece because it's a Gish gallop it's
just gif calop is a debate term where
you just throw out a bunch of stuff and
particularly on Fox News Brian Kilmeade
is not going to be the guy to go through
step-by-step so first he says there's
been a plan for decades whose plan a
plan by whom where was it crafted
because the Marxists themselves are
almost completely non-existent like
there's not even that many socialists
most socialists are not actually
Marxists either Marxism has been around
as a theory since the 1800s so who
exactly has been working on this plan
for decades to bring this 1800s idea to
the United States for decades and if
they've been doing it for decades
they've clearly failed miserably because
there are still almost no Marxists at
all in the United States and certainly
no Marxists in positions of power so so
that part is not true then he sort of
starts taking advantage of this idea of
the left wants to make the u.s. look bad
or portray the US as evil and this is
maybe easier to do right now because the
left is in the opposition when you have
Donald Trump this wild authoritarian
surrounded by right-wing nuts in power
we are rightly pointing out that a lot
is going wrong in the country but that
doesn't mean we're Marxists or
socialists I'm certainly neither and
he's taking advantage of the situation
that has left the
left that has placed the left in a
position of having to say the u.s. is a
bad actor in some cases the US is a bad
actor on coronavirus because of the
failed response from Trump and mostly
Republican governors that doesn't mean
the country is in and of itself bad
that's a very simplistic and childish
sort of way to categorize countries it's
cartoonish thinking the real view is the
United States as a country given how
rich we are could be a force for so much
more good than it is and that's what we
want to get back to and it doesn't mean
a socialist takeover or a Marxist
uprising
so again gish gallop from Dan Crenshaw
here's another clip where Crenshaw
blames the police brutality the
anti-police brutality protesters for the
spike in cases in Texas rather than
Texas reopening too early let's take a
look at that but we're gonna get through
this it's a virus without a vaccine and
we always knew this kind of thing would
happen especially when we had tens of
thousands of people in the streets just
a couple weeks ago okay this shouldn't
have just sort of surprised no one over
300 cities 300 plus cities had some type
of rioting looting protests happening
how do people not link those two in fact
I've seen reports saying no proof that
the riots and the streets in the protest
led to the rise of coronavirus well
you'd have to suspend logic to think
that yeah don't believe your lying eyes
everybody wants to say it was a few
people hanging out of bars that caused
this that's not true listen Texas has
been reopening since May first oK we've
been getting back to normalcy since May
first and everything was declining as a
result cases were declining this spikes
happened after tens of thousands of
people got together in close proximity
again there's nothing wrong with saying
that that's that's just the truth and
we're just dealing with it now it's not
it's not about blaming anybody it's just
about being honest with with causes and
effects so notice that Brian Kilmeade
says you know we had rioting and looting
and protesting like what we mostly had
was actually protesting this is a
linguistic tool that's used you first
mentioned the rioting and the looting
and then you mentioned the protesting
always frame things as mostly violent
when you're against the mess
but the real meat here is the cases
which Dan Crenshaw says is him being
honest listen we got to be honest it's
the anti-police brutality protests that
spiked cases now I set up front the
virus knows no political ideology the
virus doesn't care whether you're
protesting against lockdowns or you're
protesting against police brutality both
can spike cases the facts happen to be
that the anti lockdown protests were
mostly people not wearing masks whereas
the anti-police brutality protests were
mostly people wearing masks not
everybody you saw a few masks at the
anti lockdown protests and you saw a few
people without masks at the anti-police
brutality protests but by and large
people were wearing masks and the masks
work even sean hannity set it on his
program last night so in New York City
and in Boston we had huge protests and
we didn't have a spike and in fact we
see a continued decline in New York and
Massachusetts in other places you had
protests and there has been a spike and
the spike appears to be mostly because
of people without masks and restaurants
we're hearing about outbreaks at nail
salons and the like and even Texas's own
governor said we probably opened bars
too early which is certainly an
admission that things have not gone
exactly right so I have my ideology as
truth and my ideology is health I was
worried there would be a major spike
because of the protests fortunately the
protestors widely wore masks and it
doesn't seem as though those protests
caused the big spike
conversely were starting to see some
elements surrounding Tulsa Oklahoma that
are seeing more rapidly increasing cases
that could be because of Trump's rally
at which 6,200 people crowded together
well crowded there was there was some
room because it was so empty but many of
them were crowded together without
wearing masks let's just tell the truth
and don't fall for Dan Crenshaw's BS hey
here's a story that this is not like a
big news story but pee
flagged it for me and it's just kind of
you know anytime there's a win in the
battle of the churning of ideas that's
the new hot phrase to churn ideas like
butter I do like to mention it Eric
Weinstein is a member of the
intellectual dark web nice guy I've
spoken to him a few times he was
interviewed by a guy named David fuller
who has a YouTube channel called rebel
wisdom I've been interviewed by David
fuller previously they had a
conversation a couple days ago and David
fuller asked Erik Weinstein an
interesting question are there any
critiques that you think have been
valuable or useful now I I can't
actually tell whether the question is
are there critiques of the intellectual
dark web that have been useful or are
there critiques of the left by people on
the left that have been useful I'm not
actually sure which the question is
asking but what was interesting was that
Erik Weinstein said a lot of people are
doing schoolyard type stuff but when
David Pakman is at his best which
clearly is not all the time that's okay
when I'm at my best I've done some good
critiques and again I don't know if it's
of the IDW or of the left from the left
let's take a look
are there any critiques that you think
would have been valuable open useful
very few there have been a few but very
few well
it's really been pretty slim pickins
David Pakman at his best I think has
been a pretty astute and fair observer
on the harder and want to call it harder
left means he's own sort of weirdly
between the woke in the IDW you know
then there are people who are very smart
like for example I think of Sam cedar is
being very informed on policy terms like
he's actually following a particular
bill or you know probably knows the
names of staffers on the hill that kind
of granular detail the problem with him
is that he's got a strong trolling game
and kind of a comedic ridicule game that
is a turn-off to I mean it's okay as a
wit but it's not okay as a main course
and so I think that you could pick
through the Sam cedar stuff and find
reasonable stuff but I wouldn't
recommend it because of the reliance on
ridicule so there is Eric Weinstein
saying I think if I understand it
correctly that when I'm at my best which
is not all the time of course I've done
some okay critiques either of the
intellectual dark web or maybe he means
critiques of the left from the left I
believe that this is a compliment now if
you've not been following the
intellectual dark web or woke nice he
says I'm between the IDW and the woke
left these are two different movements
that have surfaced at least starting
online the intellectual dark web is a
sort of group of commentators who could
be on the left or on the right but their
big thing is they're opposed to identity
politics they're opposed to political
correctness and sacred cows language
policing restrictions on speech taboos
etc it includes people like Eric
Weinstein himself as well as his brother
Brett it includes sam Harris and Michael
Shermer and then I don't know who else
is within it or or outside of it I'm not
really sure the woke movement or woke
Ness refers generally to the left-wing
movement that includes
a particular type of cultural awareness
around race and feminism and LGBT
activism and socially liberal causes
racial justice is a big thing and it's
sometimes used as a pejorative and
sometimes it's not sometimes it's have
you become woke as a positive thing I
think in this context Eric is using woke
nests as a pejorative and IDW as good
and maybe is placing me between the two
so as soon as this happened there were
people online furious that if Eric
Weinstein is saying something good about
david pakman david pakman must be really
bad other people saw this and said hey
that's actually pretty interesting what
I'm hearing I'm leaving it at this it
sounds to me like Eric is just saying
I'm at least honest and genuine in my
critiques I know that Eric has not
agreed with every one of my critiques of
the IDW we've spoken about it before and
that's fine but for me this is less
about oh where do I agree or disagree
with the woke left or with the IDW for
me it's more about my commitment to you
as a viewer or listener has always been
I'm not going to just say stuff for
clicks when it's not really what I
believe if what I really believe
generates interest and builds and
audience that's great if it doesn't and
you all know there have been cases where
I've just given you my opinion and lost
subscribers well then that's too bad but
my priority is I'll tell you things as I
see them and hopefully me being genuine
and honest is what Eric is pointing to
here
I've spoken to Eric about having him on
the program still an open invitation to
do it anytime he's ready we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two david p here's a seemingly
simple question about trump take a
listen
hello David I just wanted to get your
take on why no one's calling for Trump's
resignation at this point in the midst
of all the crap that he's done thank you
right so listen you and I know that
Donald Trump has
done you know enough to warrant ten
resignations and five impeachments at
this point I don't know that there's
much of a benefit to calling for his
resignation the elections in four months
right I mean we if we reelect him if the
country reelect him after everything
that's gone on clearly the whack jobs
are in the majority I mean there's and
and and we're gonna have to figure out
some other way to fix the country I
don't know that there's much value in
calling for resignation now I think we
should focus on let's just get this guy
out were four months away he could be
out in six and we could have a different
president that's where I'm not denying
he should resign I'm not denying he
should have been impeached at this point
I don't know what what we're really
hoping for because it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen we've got a great
bonus show for you today we'll talk
about the Seattle protest zone we will
talk about the road block to electric
vehicles in America's future it's not a
bad road block we'll talk about it and
much much more join me on the bonus show
by becoming a member at join pakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show I'll see you then
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue chicom and use the promo code david
i've put a link right underneath this
video